>> Tucker: DANA, THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
IT WAS GREAT TO SEE YOU TONIGHT.
>> Dana: THANK YOU, BYE-BYE.
>> Tucker: TWO MORE
INSTITUTIONS UNDER FURTHER
ATTACK THE SECOND AMENDMENT AND
OBJECTIVE PRESS.
THIS WEEK, RECEIVED SOMETHING
CALLED CRONKITE AWARD, YOU
DIDN'T WIN BUT THEY DID.
THEY WON FOUR FULL-BLOWN
PROPAGANDA EVENT THAT THEY
STAGED AFTER LAST YEAR'S PARK
WHEN SHOOTING.
IT WAS A TOWN HALL ON GUN
VIOLENCE.
IT WAS TRANSPARENT EXCUSE TO
AMBUSH ANYONE WHO SUPPORTS THE
SECOND AMENDMENT AND ANNOUNCE
THEM ON NATIONAL TELEVISION,
WHICH IS WHAT HAPPENED.
>> I THINK WHAT YOU ARE ASKING
ABOUT IS THE ASSAULT WEAPONS,
MAN.
>> YES, SIR.
>> LET ME BE HONEST WITH THAT
ONE.
IF I BELIEVE THAT LOWE WOULD
HAVE PREVENTED THIS FROM
HAPPENING TO HIM I WOULD SUPPORT
IT.
BUT I WANT TO EXPLAIN TO YOU WHY
IT DOES NOT.
>> CAN YOU TELL ME RIGHT NOW
THAT YOU WILL NOT ACCEPT A
SINGLE DONATION FROM THE NRA?
[APPLAUSE]
>> I WISH IN OUR LADY -- NRA
LADY I COULD TALK TO CONSIDERING
THE FACT THAT SHE HAS CHILDREN
THAT SHE CAN EVEN LOOK IN THE
MIRROR.
>> LET ME ASK THE QUESTION YOU
CAN SHOUT ME DOWN AFTER I'M
FINISHED BUT LET ME ANSWER THE
QUESTION.
I WOULD DO EVERYTHING IN MY
POWER TO PREVENT THAT.
>> YOU JUST TOLD THIS GROUP OF
PEOPLE THAT YOU ARE STANDING UP
FOR THEM.
YOU ARE NOT STANDING UP FOR
THEM.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Tucker: SUCH DEMAGOGUES.
A SPOKESPERSON FOR THE NRA WAS
AT THE TOWN HALL.
YOU SAW THE TAPE AND SHE JOINS
US TONIGHT.
IT IS UPSETTING TO WATCH THAT
TAPE BECAUSE IT IS SO UNFAIR.
IT IS A MOB BASICALLY SCREAMING
AT YOU BUT WHAT WAS ELECT TO BE
THERE?
>> Dana: TUCKER, THANK YOU FOR
TALKING ABOUT THIS.
WE HAVE LEARNED SO MANY THINGS
SINCE THAT TIME, RIGHT, GOT
ISRAEL ON THE STAGE.
I DON'T KNOW HOW TO DESCRIBE IT.
WHEN WE FOUND OUT THE TOWN HOLD
TAKING PLACE ON A WEDNESDAY, I
WAS GOING THERE TUESDAY.
I FOUND OUT I WAS GOING TO BE
ASKED QUESTIONS THAT AFTERNOON
WHILE I WAS ON THE PLANE, AND IT
WASN'T UNTIL I GOT THERE THAT I
FOUND OUT I WAS GOING TO BE ON
STAGE.
LATER, SCOTT ISRAEL.
THEY ACTUALLY QUEUED ME TO WALK
OUT INTO THE ARENA TO BLACK-EYED
PEAS SONG AND THAT IS AFTER THE
CAMERA STOPPED ROLLING WITH CNN.
BUT WHAT CNN DID NOT TELL PEOPLE
THEY ALLOWED AND INVITED
POLITICIANS TO COME UP ON STAGE
AND ELECTION YEARS.
SCOTT ISRAEL TO MAKE A BIDDING
SPEECH BEFORE THIS EVEN BEGAN IN
WHICH HE ALREADY STARTED
DEFLECTING BLAME BY PUTTING IT
ON ME.
IT WAS TREATED AS THIS, I THINK,
THEY TRIED TO STYLIZE THIS TO
MAKE IT MOST EMOTIONALLY
IMPACTFUL.
I QUESTION THE ETHICS OF THEM
PUTTING IT ON THIS WAY.
TUCKER, THIS WAS NOT A
JOURNALISTIC ENDEAVOR.
THEY HAD THIS TOWN HALL
LITERALLY TITLED IT WAS CALLED
"STAND UP THE STUDENTS OF
MARJORIE STONE DOUGLAS DEMAND
ACTION."
THAT IS NOT A JOURNALISTIC
ENDEAVOR, THAT HIS ADVOCACY.
>> Tucker: I WOULDN'T QUESTION
THE ETHICS BUT THIS IS FLAT OUT
UNETHICAL AND I CANNOT IMAGINE
WHY THEY WOULD WIN A AWARD.
THEY SHOULD BE ASHAMED WHAT THEY
DID.
PEOPLE WERE REALLY HOSTILE
TOWARDS YOU.
WHAT WAS THAT LIKE?
>> Dana: I HAVE NEVER BEEN IN
A SITUATION LIKE THAT.
I'VE NEVER BEEN IN A SITUATION
WHERE THAT I HAD SOMEONE RUSH ME
FROM BEHIND AND TRY TO GET ME
AND A MEMBER OF MY DETAIL.
I GRABBED -- I SHOWED UP TO TALK
ABOUT THE ISSUE AT HAND.
NOT JUST THIS TOWN HALL BUT YOU
WILL REMEMBER TUCKER AT THAT
PARTICULAR NETWORK TO STAND
UNCHALLENGED ON THEIR
AIRWAVES ACCUSATIONS NOT
JUST MY INTEGRITY AS A PERSON
AND AS A MOTHER, BUT ALSO
MILLIONS OF LAW-ABIDING GUN
OWNERS ALL ACROSS THE
UNITED STATES.
THEIR INTEGRITY WAS QUESTION AND
THEY ARE GENUINENESS WAS
QUESTION AND QUESTIONING THE
SAME PEOPLE JUST BECAUSE THEY
THOUGHT DIFFERENTLY.
WHAT THEY DID, WHAT THIS
TOWN HALL DID, WAS SET DIALOGUE
BACK BY I DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH.
IT PUSHED DIALOGUE BACK.
IT WAS AN EMBARRASSING DISPLAY
OF BIAS.
THEY SHOULD FEEL ASHAMED INSTEAD
OF BACK PATTING THEMSELVES.
FOR THEM TO SAY THIS ADVANCE THE
NATIONAL CONVERSATION ON CAN
CONTROL IS LIKE SAYING THE SALEM
WITCH TRIALS ADVANCE THE
CONVERSATION ON WOMEN'S RIGHTS.
THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT THIS WAS
LIKE.
IT WAS AN EMBARRASSMENT AND THEY
SHOULD BE ASHAMED.